what is a dangling cause dangling cause
is one of the tools that keeps the
audience anticipating and it comes from
belief French formalism narratology the
narrative theory and the I simply stated
we we respond we talked about this them
but to cause an effect we look for cause
and effect we are geared toward
understanding the world that way and
it's easy for us to follow stories
narrative events when there is a cause
and effect it's evident dangling cause
is a cause that you don't get the effect
right away but you anticipate so boy
likes girl boy kisses girl cause of
effect boy likes girl boy says I'm going
to kiss her before the weekend is over
dangling comes we're gonna pick up that
effect later but it dangles over in the
audience's consciousness so it's one of
the tools in the screenwriting of the
feat the sequence approach that we talk
and that I talk about that helps keep
the audience wondering what's going to
happen next
I mentioned deadlines that's one
telegraphing sort of what is coming
literally there's an appointment at five
o'clock today we're going to meet at
Jerry to santeria tell the audience that
when you cut there you don't have to
explain why we're there you've been told
the deadline like The Hurt Locker or
even yeah the the one American American
Beauty we know what it's good that when
he's close to being dead it's gonna
movies gonna be over there's dramatic
irony where we are engaged because we're
going to see what happens when the truth
comes out and then there's a traumatic
tension which is when we're wondering
what how would the person get what they
want or not or will they escape what
they want or not and I think if there's
anything in my approach what we're
trying to do here that I emphasize with
the students is there's always talk
about rules should I follow the rule
should I break the rules should I do
this or that and to me the problem with
rules is or
understanding rules or even if you want
to call them guidelines is that if you
follow the rules congratulations you're
one down you're following you're
following you're not leading you're
following and having followed them the
rules don't applaud and they don't pay
you anything a better question to ask is
what's the effect what's the effect of
my choice in the story on my audience
because now I'm one up I'm in charge of
what's happening I'm in charge of how
I'm affecting my audience and the tools
that are in these books that's the idea
what are the choices that you didn't
know you have that you have that you can
use to affect the audience and audiences
do applaud and they pay you so I like my
students to be in the power position
where they're figuring out what they
want to do rather than what whether they
can follow something so true or false if
we focus on the audience everything will
fall into place with our screenplay if
fall into place
true or false no nuance we focus on the
audience we can we have a better shot of
succeeding at connecting with an
audience that's the closest I can come
so focusing on the audience keeping
structure and mind sequences things like
that okay yep and it gives you that
freedom you know if you know what
they're anticipating you can play games
you you how do you break a rule well
Alfred Hitchcock I don't want to give it
away but Alfred Hitchcock exploited the
fact that in a Hollywood movie there's a
main character and the main characters
star and the star lives through the
movie maybe they die in the end but they
live through the movie knowing that
that's what the audience is expecting
what happens if you kill them off 40
minutes in well that's going to have a
huge effect well but you can do other
things to make up for the loss if you
understand what the function of a
character is then you can create do
something else to compensate for that
and keep the audience interested even
though the characters gone I'll leave
you with one joke and I know
you got a and but it's it's like this if
you were to write a book knock-knock
jokes what would you do you would say he
would look at all the knock-knock jokes
you say it's very simple these are the
rules you say knock knock the other
person says who's there
you give a partial answer they say
partial answer who and then you give
them the the punchline okay that's the
rules that's my book and that's that's
how you if you want to be successful
okay
knock knock oh who's there
control freak okay now here's where you
say control freak ooh see I just broke
the rules but what I was doing was
trying to elicit a laugh the point was
the effect not the rules it's knowing
what you think exploiting the fact that
you have a schema an understanding of
what a knock-knock joke is I can play
games
you